yeah that is sort of like the the the
offline equivalent to somebody finding
an address book and
literally ringing every number in there
or yeah or
text text all your contacts you know
like oh yeah yeah
text all that that sort of thing so it's
very similar to that but it's just that
in their case all was the entire
internet
with the original unix systems where we
had a system called write where you
could write to other people
and that was very handy for in fact
i'll do a quick screen uh grab of
that working this then is an attempt to
try and reconstruct what it looked a
little like
in the 1980s when we were all working
on mainframe or mini
computers at that time so in this case
it was a pdp 1170 which was sitting in
the basement
there were terminals all around the
building all
physically wired in so there's a wire
from each terminal
down through the trunking to the
basement and plugged into the back of
the
pdp 1170 there was a room with about 20
or so terminals
that were general use and then the staff
people all had terminals in their own
office
and you'd sit down at the terminal and
you'd log in and do whatever you're
going to do
often the first thing you type is who
which would show you who is connected
onto the computer who is logged in and
who is
available and this is kind of a common
thing i would see
early on there's dave browsford logged
in eric foxley
andy walker william armitage and a
computer file and
also me of course as uh systems evolved
a little weak we had another command
called w which
did much the same thing you could see
who's logged in there
and also what they're running
in this case they're all running the
shell but you could also see the idle
time there this
this column down here that would give
you an idea of whether
they had recently done anything on the
computer or whether they'd wandered away
so if you wanted to go and talk to
someone you could see if they're
actually at their computer even better
than that you could uh
communicate directly with them so there
was a
small utility called write which allowed
you to write to somebody else
and this obviously saved you walking
around the building to try and find them
if you could see they were logged in
and uh available you could just go ahead
and say
right dfb in this case
and uh down here you can see
a message has appeared
then type and uh it would appear there
and
dfb could write back and you know it's
quite primitive but
uh we used it quite a lot and write was
actually a very simple program
it just read a line and wrote it
to the user's device
that was really very useful during the
early days that uh
because in the early days we're all
connected to the same computer and we're
all sort of a big community and
if you did something that used up a lot
of uh processing power or something
everybody would shout at you and you'd
get
these messages coming to you but it was
also
good just to uh before wandering around
the apartment to go and see if
anybody was uh logged into the computer
and you could go and chat to them
and you can actually see uh the user's
device here if you
type who then this this line here this
tty
or a pseudo tty in this case is is the
actual uh
device and that's actually a device in
the file system on unix so you could
actually
look at that so pts
two is dfbs although the security has
been uh up since then so i'll have to
play a couple of tricks to get this to
work you can actually do that directly
you can just
and just echo something straight into
that file and it appears
over here on on this file so
that's you know it's really quite simple
uh
as i say uh security's improved since
then so you can't do that now
and even then though you could say
message and that says
either yes or no so you could say
message no i don't want to receive
messages
so if he now tried to write it back then
it would say
sorry he doesn't want to be communicated
to at the moment
if you're busy but usually most people
around with that aren't whatever you
happen to be doing it just appeared in
the middle of your screen so
if you're in the middle of an editor um
you know if i put that back on and start
adding
something here
then this just appears splashed across
your screen and you
have to refresh it to get rid of it so
that was uh one system
it's kind of like a precursor to the
instant messaging i guess but
uh very very very primitive as uh as you
might show in
some of the screen crafts uh then we
also had this program called wall
which was a sort of a building up from
that from right to all users
and that was typically used either if
things got desperate on the computers
that uh somebody was
using far too much cpu and it was
effective everybody simply might
send a wall message to all the users
saying okay
own up who's burning through all the cpu
and slowing all my
stuff down but it was also part of the
shutdown process if
you tried to shut down the computer then
usually you'd give it a time and say
shut down in five minutes and it would
broadcast this message to all the users
saying
the machine is going down but that used
this command called wall
and and that would appear on
everybody's terminal so uh that was
quite
a useful thing we didn't i don't think
you could use
uh wall as a regular user i think you
have to be a system admin because it
you know splattered across everyone's
terminals
it was quite fun as we had this
room called c30 with the banks of
terminals and when somebody sent a wall
message it would sort of
appear on the first one second
accompanied by a load of beeps as well
so it would sort of ripple across the
whole terminal
room saying a machine is going down and
you certainly knew about it because they
had quite a loud beat these tvi 912s
then as we
slowly moved into the sort of uh
internet
networking version of this i remember we
received our first couple of sun
machines
in the department and i started looking
at those and seeing what uh commands
they had
they had another new command called talk
where you could that was a bit more
interactive and you could chat with
somebody with this there was only two
ways i remember
i think it may have been extended into
multi-way later
but that was basically like the right
you just typed in stuff and uh
you could see it but amongst the
commands that you got with the new sun
system now that we're all networked was
a load of commands that were started
with r
so there's an r shell to log in remotely
to
a computer which has been subsumed by
ssh
now a secure shell because it certainly
wasn't secure
there was an r exec to run programs
there was um
there was an ahu and a few other things
but but you had a bunch of these new
commands
with the letter r in front of them and
while i was looking through them i
discovered
this command called our wall which was
the remote version of wool
so you could write to all users across
the network
and i do remember looking at this and
there was some configuration
examples and one of the configurations
they have this file called netgroups
that said
this is a sort of a shorthand for who
you want to contact so you could sort of
say our wall
to all people on your local network
or pick out a specific set of machines
that it would broadcast to
but i do remember looking at it and
thinking this is a bit odd because
there's a universal group there
and they defined the universal group as
sort of the absence of everything so you
could say i think
which users you want to talk to which
machines and which networks but if you
missed all of those out
then the default was to send it to
everywhere
literally everywhere literally
everywhere that was fine on
at nottingham because there's only like
about 10 computers on the network at
this point so
i never did try down but you know the
worst that could happen it was it would
affect 10 computers
anyway uh getting to the uh the crux of
the story so uh this was uh
something that happened in 1987 march
31st actually
and it was uh started by jordan hubbard
who was quite well known at the time i
think he's quite uh well known in the
early internet he did a lot of good work
with free software and so on and he was
manager of one of berkeley's um
distributed
uh computing groups at the time and he
too like
me i suspect looked at these new
commands and said oh
this our wall thing oh that that could
be interesting i'll
i'll send a quick message to all the
people on the network
and this universal group seems to be
what uh
what is needed to uh send it around
so he he uh sent a quick message using
this all wall command
and uh not quite realizing what happened
uh it didn't come back instantly usually
it comes back quite quickly and says yes
done done that but it didn't so he sort
of left it and wandered off
and went off to see if anybody had
received it
and when he got back to his uh
workstation and sat down
he did work out that quite a lot of
people have received it
in fact everybody on the internet at the
time was
starting to receive this so he killed
the program but by that time
the damage was done and he started
getting a flood of emails
in fact he got 743 emails from people
all around the internet uh including
because at this time the internet and
the arpanet were still
somewhat connected so they hadn't really
set off the the military part from the
regular internet so
this sort of went you know around places
like the pentagon
um you know the the arpanet management
everybody suddenly got this message
splattered across their screen saying
what was the message what did he
actually say i don't know what the
message was actually i think it was just
something innocuous like hello
whatever but but it was always preceded
by quite a few lines saying
this is a broadcast message from whoever
and you've got quite a lot of the bell
command
the bell characters so it went ding ding
ding ding ding ding on your terminal and
then
went across and on the sun you typically
like like you do now you have several
windows open wallet but it sort of hit
every window there so so it's flat
across every window saying
something something important like um hi
guys i'm just testing this out or
something like that
so it caused quite a stir at the time
and apparently the
some of the high up people in the
internet uh were
extremely annoyed by this and there was
um the elders of the internet
yes they contacted son and said you know
what the hell do you think you're doing
letting people just do this sort of
thing and we demand this is patched in
your very next release and uh get a
quick fix out
all this thing uh jordan meanwhile was
um he
was uh obviously um inundated with
messages i said 743 messages which he
to his credit replied to each one
individually with sort of a stock answer
so there's quite a few versions of that
floating around
yeah it's a little unfortunate you know
he he's done a lot of good work
i think he works for nvidia now so yeah
he's a
very talented software engineer but if
you look at his wikipedia page it
does list a few of those things but half
of it is about this our wall incident
that
uh that triggered you probably made a
few friends
doing that actually i think probably 50
uh when you get to look at it there's
certainly a lot of people
you know it wasn't malicious at all or
anything like that it was just
annoying at that time was nottingham on
the internet no we weren't we were
sort of we had abridged the internet
and uh so it was
yeah it wouldn't have queued and waited
to get to you though whoever's there
right now
yeah i think it got to university
college london who
we worked with quite a lot in those days
and they were on the end of the
satellite
link at that point i think it got
through to them
i think i had a few uh friends who who
got it but it
luckily didn't get through to us and uh
i guess it didn't get through to
everyone because apparently the way it
worked was it said oh
this this is going to everybody right i
will go through all the list of known
hosts on your computer and just go
through one at a time contacting each
and send send it off there and at that
point we hadn't got the dns
it was still a sort of a host list file
so it just went
all the way through there and uh and
because they were
actually very well connected avertly to
the internet
it managed to get everywhere right so
we're here
we can't go to s we can only go to l
that's a nice easy one so i need to find
l
so l goes to c and it's three plus two
is five
so l comes in one column to start with
and each of these nodes with within
network has connections to other nodes
this is how you initialize network